back to like youtube boomer talk right
yeah
you talk you talked about you know
constantly learning constantly seeing
what's out there yeah there must have
been a point when you're just like i am
so out of touch right now oh i always
because i constantly feel that sometimes
i'm like i get youtube i get i get the
algorithm i get all the content but i
get what people want to watch sometimes
you just see something and you're like
okay i am a boomer you see that one
popular video and you're like why yeah
why there's this one channel uh called
ouija pg
have
no okay so uh i don't know how they do
it they it's they got um
they like they have a 3d cg
rig of
luigi and they animate him in his face
be to react to things or at least this
is what this is what the channel was a
few years ago i don't know what they're
doing now okay uh so he was reacting to
things with
luigi sound effects they're like wow
and it was just like a reaction channel
by luigi and i was like and some of them
had millions of views and i was like
this is so bizarre
but i loved it
that was incredible i reached out i
followed him on twitter i was like this
[ __ ] keep it up this shit's sick but it
was so weird and that's i was like there
was always something to learn
about youtube yeah yeah yeah there's
always some weird corner yeah
i mean now you're exploring that yeah
now you're exploring yeah yeah and those
are the types of people that i really
really enjoy talking to where it's like
this community that's doing this thing
that's that many people just think is
bizarre like no yeah there's actually
something to it and why does it catch on
and we could talk about the emotional
aspects of
like
the connection that people make and why
do you think this is popular i think
it's just really refreshing you know i
mean obviously lately on the internet
you know and even when you started it it
was very competitive and everyone was
always at each other's throat and i
think it just came out of the time and
kind of hit the right note of just like
let's just talk let's just yeah yeah
like
learn about each other yeah
yeah yeah and i i think it's yeah i mean
the success i mean it shows that the
audiences wanted that kind of content
like yeah yeah people are curious about
all the types of different things be it
pony
pony pony players
[Music]
in saying that i want to know that
i want to know why like in saying that
though there have been a couple of
videos i've seen from yours where you do
kind of bring back that like old school
like a little bit cynical type of
interviewer like you know the one about
like you interviewing time travelers for
instance like that one was like a little
like i saw like the little bit of the
super cool side yeah which was just as
entertaining you have to be yeah yeah
yeah that was right after the flat
earthers episode
quite detached from that yeah
um
but i feel like now if i were to
approach that again yeah the topic that
i'm like a little bit like
yeah i think i would just outright say
this seems completely unbelievable right
yeah do you have people telling you that
and how do you feel about that right
yeah i feel like there's so many more
interesting conversations to have about
that
and i think a lot of people are uh
either afraid to tell someone that their
shit's whack or they
all they want to do is tell them that
their shit's whack and they don't want
to hear why they do what they do right
right i think that there's like if you
could just be transparent with
anyone really like if you just have a
conversation with anyone about why they
do what they do you can make some kind
of a connection regardless of who the
person is except hitler not hitler
yeah they grow up so far
[Applause]
how do you feel about how do you feel
about tick tock because if there's one
thing that does make me feel like a
boomer and out of touch it is just tick
tock itself
yeah
have you thought about adventuring into
that oh we i have a tic tac
yeah yeah
yeah it does really well with just clips
yeah from
my my interview series cut down and yeah
we did that as well yeah yeah yeah it
doesn't work for you guys yeah yeah yeah
yeah well i think that the thing about
tick tock is that there is a an audience
for everything oh yeah so you might log
on and think this is [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
but then
there is a corner of the internet that
is for you on tick tock and their
algorithm is really good at feeding you
content eventually if you get even if
you sift through enough garbage for
enough time and eventually you will find
the thing that that sits
my favorite category of tip-top videos
is somebody complaining about something
really specific and then someone's like
hi i'm the expert on that actually
that's actually why it works and he's
like who's who's the toenail expert why
don't you come here
it's literally irl reddit right yeah
yeah
don't tell no like here let me explain
to you it's just like the the strangest
experts all come out and they're all
good looking like that's the other thing
everyone who is like an expert on
something is just amazing looking yeah
there is always an expert about
everything and they look amazing and
they're always like they always look
amazing it's like you why did you have
to be so good and charming did they
become good looking because they're an
expert or which one came first they
became an expert then they had the time
to go and walk out and take care of them
or is it that most people that look good
or bound to be experts
i used to be a model now i'm a toenail
yeah
it is really crazy yeah but it's such a
cool platform but it makes me feel
really old yeah and it's weird because i
thought it was gonna die
i think everyone when it when it was
bought when it was musically yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i thought it was going to go down
the vine route back yeah yeah yeah
musically was the thing and everyone was
doing the musically like cringe
compilations right i just thought that's
just [ __ ] for kids yeah blew up and then
wow everyone was wrong i think everyone
thought it was going to die yeah yeah
yeah when everyone just was just like
that lip-synching or doing dances and
just like look at this funny thing the
kids are doing they were okay anthony
was like i did that
my career that way they took my [ __ ] i
think it's the replies the replies and
the ability to share the music so easily
yeah yeah game changer i think yeah and
it made editing kind of
you know accessible to the i mean
editing uh very accessible to beginners
and like yeah people who don't know it
it's like did you just slide this thing
across chop the video chuck it and put
this music over it and you want a funny
filter we've got that too yeah so it
kind of made it more like less scary i
mean you open up like da vinci resolve
and you just have a panic attack you're
like what the [ __ ] is this this makes no
sense adobe premiere makes zero sense if
you don't watch five hours of youtube
yeah yeah yeah so i feel like it kind of
made it like very accessible in a way
that kind of just worked and tick-tock
is always changing their [ __ ] yeah yeah
if you look at tick tock now versus a
year ago it looks very different yeah
for that and the features that they add
they are doing the upkeep yeah uh vine
like they i mean i think it was clear
why vine died for many reasons one being
that you couldn't make money on it but
also
they were not like keeping it up they
were not updating it and then
unfortunately or not
things on the internet platforms are
need to constantly be updated to go
where people are wanting it to go yeah
because it is ultimately four people
right yeah yeah yeah instead vine opted
to be like what if we made a sequel to
vine let's make a vine too did they ever
do that
no no were those rumors or were those
legit they were they were legit yeah
vine was like we're coming back with
vine to people and then tick tock was
like nah yeah i was like no we go
yeah well i find it really weird because
like i feel like now tick tock is what
youtube was like you know 10 15 years
ago right where you know like remember
when in back in the day where youtubers
would try to get on tv which was like
the old media in order to legitimize
themselves and now it's like tick-tock
is trying to become youtubers
themselves it's been so weird just
seeing that transition that's so true
yeah i guess it's because the platform
is so easily accessible yeah you were
saying that anyone could jump on there
and you can build an audience yeah on
there people can find you the algorithm
is very good so it's basically like
if early youtube had an algorithm that
fed people content that was directly
relevant to them yeah and i think it's
also like the barrier for entry for
youtube now i feel like even though you
know youtuber is like you know you can
make anything on youtube and it will be
successful you know still like the the
quality of content on youtube now is so
much higher than it was 15 years ago
we're in like the the mr beast era where
everything has to be a hundred thousand
dollars
i [ __ ] stayed up for one week
straight like it's like all right okay i
can't compete with that because i just
don't want to do that yeah have you seen
any of ryan trehan's i have my house so
he i feel like he's been reinventing uh
yeah yeah what youtubers can now
expect to do with the platform because
he's taking some elements of the mr b
style
thumbnails that look very nice and clean
and he has
an elevated concept right for this whole
thing it feels like a video game it
feels like you're watching this person's
journey
in front of you and you feel like you
can't click away because you never know
what's gonna happen
but yet it is still a vlog and he can
still
um you know because it is a
vlog where the whole idea is that it's
low produced yeah he's able to make one
a day it's quite nice yeah watching it
and you're like this is like nice i just
feel like it's not too crazy yeah like
you know obviously i love nostalgia i
love watching a mr beast video but my
god i feel like i'm a cog in a machine
yeah
absolutely so much and there's so much
screaming and texting yeah
it feels like a refined modernized vlog
that has yeah yeah kind of like an
elevated
game plan the thumbnails are just the
thumbnails kill it and i never would
have thought that a vlog thumbnail which
is not you know
click bait because it's not clickbait it
couldn't look so good yeah yeah right
i don't know who does like i remember
you know where back when uh you know
youtuber vlogs were just you know you
put on any digital camera you know
handheld camera and then casey neistat
came along and just used a dslr and made
like basically like mini short films
every day and people were like what you
can do that that's possible and then
everyone tried to be casey neistat for a
while and then he burnt out and then he
burnt out you know i mean he was every
day yeah i mean when he used to talk
about his schedule he was like yeah i'd
wake up at 4 a.m and i'm editing it on
the plane i'm like yeah what the [ __ ]
but i think what we can learn from that
experience is
that you know if you have something good
you don't need to over do it yeah if you
wanted to have any longevity you know
part of the game plan is to figure out a
way for it not to take up your entire
life yeah you know i interviewed market
player and he was like burnout is when
people aren't refilling their bucket
they're they're constantly scooping out
of their bucket for their content and
they're refilling it because they're not
living a life outside of that yeah you
need to have that balance yeah have you
ever been burnt out
uh
yes absolutely
i was not shocked if you said no
never
always always uh
uh many different times and every single
time it was when i felt overworked
um and then once it became like part of
a company overworked underappreciated
yeah yeah um felt like i wasn't being um
like my my opinions didn't
uh quite contribute to the creative
right um but then also outside of that i
i was burnt out on my own outside of
smosh after i left and decided to do my
own thing right um for a lot of that
time when the views were dropping uh i
was also burnt out so it makes sense
that people were not wanting to watch
the content of someone who's burned the
[ __ ] out by their own content that's
like that's not fun to watch you can
there's a feeling you can feel when
someone is burnt out by their yeah and
then when you go to the the actual video
and the top comment is like he's run out
of ideas
i'm like [ __ ] you dude i got so many
ideas and i just sit there i'm like i
have no idea
they were right [ __ ]
call me
but uh you know i
i think i i really
started to reframe
what was important to me and then i
started like not taking it as seriously
not putting as much of my time into it
and i was able to
live a life outside of it and have
thoughts that were separate from my work
that's right it kind of helps
reinvigorate